جدل وقضايا عده اثارها قانون 230 الامريكي
ابرز القضايا قضيه الشابه الامريكيه
في اعتداءات باريس عام 2015 حيث قدم
والدها شكوى ضد جوجل المنصه يوتيوب بسبب
بروز تنظيم داعش من خلال اقتراحات مقاطع
مصوره لبعض المستخدمين الامر الذي اعتبر
دعما للتنظيم الارهابي القضيه الثانيه
رفعتها عائله الاردني نورس العساف وهو
الذي قتل بهجوم اسطنبول الارهابي عام 2017
حيث تدعي اسرته ان المنصات التواصليه مثل
تويتر وجوجل وفيسبوك سمحت لداعش
باستخدامها وبالتالي التحريض على الارهاب
وفي عام 2021 اعرب القاضي المحافظ كلارنس
عن اسفه لان المحاكم فسرت القانون 230
بشكل فضفاض ومنحت حصانه واسعه جدا لبعض
اكبر شركات الانترنت في العالم مثيرا جدلا
كبيرا لكن شركه التكنولوجيا وعلى راسها
متى تحذر من تعرضها للملاحقات ربما يجعلها
عرضه لشكاوي المتواصله لا تنتهي
[موسيقى]